um there's a question here from Laura
Ann via Twitter which which sort of
connects to this she says a lot of your
female characters are very empowered and
motivated which other fictional or
historical female characters did you
draw inspiration from if any um
well again it was a lot of them eleanor
of aquitaine of course was was a major
one she was one of the most kick-ass
women of of the Middle Ages and as you
know she had her own crusade or she went
on crusade rather and she married two
kings and then was the father of several
or was the mother of several more she
was a great character there's also a lot
of the if you read the Italian history a
lot of the during the Italian Middle
Ages and and Renaissance period there
were a lot of very powerful and bloody
women who controlled various city-states
in Italy and and did some amazing things
there's one very famous story that again
is probably made up by some popular
historian or legend maker because it
occurs in like the same story is told of
like six different men and at least two
different women and it's the one where
they that the father and or mother is in
a castle and they have a son outside who
they're going to hang you know surrender
the castle we're gonna hang your son
right in front of you and this story is
told of William Marshall the great
Knights father you know who supposedly
pulled up his his jerkin or whatever the
hell he was wearing and show them his
dick and and said go ahead hang him I
have equipment to make more
and that same story is also told of I
think Catherine's sabor zone if the
Italians where you know they were gonna
hang her son and then she lifted up her
skirts and pointed at her vagina and
said no I could make another one right
here so probably it never happened at
all since it's attached to six people
but god it's a great story I can't
resist things like that and then don't
be surprised if I steal it and you see
it no later again but every time that a
season of Game of Thrones would be about
to come on television in the UK someone
from a newspaper would ring me up and
say hey can you we got this great idea
can you write an essay about how Game of
Thrones is really just the Wars of the
Roses and I'd say yeah sure pay me and
I'll of course there's a second
secondary industry and george RR martin
material and i'm part of it um it's not
it I mean that clearly stark and
Lannister York and Lancaster I mean
there are all of these how how much was
it drawn from the wars the Roses how
much was that sort of just convenient
material for you to suck into this with
this world there were certainly an
inspiration and probably the worst of
grossest of a single greatest historical
inspiration but I'd read a lot of
popular history I also read you know the
history of the Crusades and and the Alba
jinseyun Crusade and the Hundred Years
War and of course a lot of Nigel Tranter
books about the the historical fiction
about the history of Scotland which
always end badly the history of Scotland
is senior league bloody if you think
Game of Thrones is violent read some
Scottish history history for the red
wedding of course yes the red wedding
was loosely based on the the black
dinner as as they called it but of
course once again I turned it up to
eleven and then David and Dan got hold
of it for a TV show and turned it up to
14 so you know you could always turn it
up a little more we've got the red so
the the black dinner though is an
interesting case I mean I I say I love
history but I always want to make it
clear that I'm not a professional
historian and the histories that I read
in histories that I love or I guess what
are called popular histories there
academic histories if you accidentally
stumble on an academic history it'll
probably put you to sleep
very quickly the stuff that the
professional historians do now the black
dinner of Scotland I don't know how many
of you know that was the there was a
emnity between the the Earl of Douglas
the black Douglas as he was called and
the King of Scotland so he invited the
Earl of Douglas giving it gave him a
safe passage to come to the castle and
discuss it and they had all day the
lovely dinner the Earl who was young
there was only like 18 19 years old and
he brought his even younger brother who
was like 15 years old with him and they
had a lovely dinner with the King of
Scotland and then at the end of it
they started playing this very sonorous
beat and some servants entered with a
covered platter underneath which was a
black Boar's Head which was a symbol of
death and so then they took the Earl and
his little 1415 year old brother out and
they beheaded both of them in New York
it's a great story and I went from that
and I constructed the the red wedding of
course that's the story in myth and in
popular legend but but then if you read
an academic historian said none of that
ever happened no they did execute the
Earl and all that but there was no
sonorous beat there was no there was no
black Boar's Head all that stuff was
invented later and maybe it was but
whoever invented it was a pretty good
storyteller because I like the popular
version of it much better than I like
the boring academic version of it I
think sometimes in this study of history
there must be someone maybe it said he's
at Harvard or Yale or at Oxford or
Cambridge over here and he I don't know
what his name is but he his job is to
sit in an office and go over history and
make it as boring as possible take out
take out all the fun bits and and the
colorful bits and make it really dull